une journée 100% business et innovation
qui s'est délocalisé cette année à la
grande arche de la défense organisée
jusqu'à présent en essonne ce rendez
vous rassemble des grands groupes des
pme et des start up
cette 14e édition tournée vers l' usine
du futur a généré près de 15000 rendez
vous d'affaires
toute cette technologie qui sont en fait
transverse entre les filières et qui
permettent justement à des start-up
d'émerger en se développant avec
plusieurs donneurs d'ordre dans
différentes filières et d'avoir une
accélération on fait de la mise en
relation durable
parmi les innovations mises en avant
lors de ce salon mobile office un
véhicule de transport collectif
connectés que testeront d'ici six mois
des salariés d'airbus entre parier
l'encours le véhicule dans lequel vous
êtes véhiculé équipe aujourd'hui
correspond voilà à 80% je dirais aux
concepts qu'on a imaginé rendez vous
annuel des décideurs de l'innovation
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les start up
de nouer des partenariats
plusieurs sociétés implantées à saint
quentin en yvelines étaient notamment
présentes on essaie de voir si on peut
trouver des 1 trouver ce qu'il soit prêt
à collaborer avec nous pour créer un
concept de jeu un concept de serious
games par exemple qui conviennent à
leurs problématiques d'entreprise nous
avons été en fait inviter au salon
tech'innove lors du scan business day
parce que nous avons reçu le deuxième
prix de l'innovation l'objectif saab est
de rencontrer un maximum de personnes
pour essayer de développer un maximum de
partenariats
au total ce rendez vous a rassemblé 214
start up et plus de 80 investisseurs